what was holding them back was blake
bortles i'm going with the rams
[Music]
i can do a little bit more than sell
newspapers chris
i love it
[Music]
that man smacks a lot harder than you oh
i know i know
stop the melvins uh we battle them later
in the show
uh welcome sims and lefko uh there's one
place we have to start yes
you are so obsessed with the quarterback
right now that you compared him
to aaron rodgers yes and i've never
heard you compare someone to aaron
rodgers
well the mahomey well come on i mean
what he is doing is special patrick
mahomes
patrick mahomes our homie and you know i
love them coming out in the draft
but what's there not to love i mean a
guy that's cool and calm
under pressure oh he's got one of the
greatest arms in the sport
i've never seen anything like what he's
doing really two games into his career
yes it's jaw-dropping no one has
anything ten touchdowns
no interceptions yeah no quarterback has
done that for the first two weeks no
but my question is we've seen this with
andy reid's team we saw it last year
5-0 6-0 and then they get figured out
right do you think he gets figured out
uh no disrespect to prior andy reid
quarterbacks but
you can't figure this out what is this
patrick mahomes makes you defend
more of the field maybe than any other
quarterback in the
history of the sport when you couple
along
tyree kill sammy watkins kelsey down the
middle
oh yeah a good smash mouth one game then
all the andy reed speed sweeps
every inch of the field has to be
guarded that's where it's going to be
special
and mahomes is the most talented
quarterback he's ever had hey
mcnabb mcnabb hey you're great man
there's no doubt alex smith you're
really good too
but this guy has a chance to be talked
about as one of the greatest players of
all time i've always felt that way and
we might have to put another shrine
behind us soon
oh my homies oh my gosh
i was gonna go another question but
honestly it's perfect because you know
what our next segment is what is that
whoa whoa big take
seems when it comes to whoa big take
this week there's only one guy that we
thought would be appropriate right
blake borders oh i have a shocker
everybody thinks that you're just a big
tank artist
right yeah yeah i know i don't sit and
watch film all week and study and i
haven't learned anything in my days from
being with john gruden or mac brown or
bill belichick
i just have takes but we're hopping in
the whoa
time machine to take you back to a
certain man's takes
a certain chris sims 2017 you said if he
gets cut by the jags he will never play
in the nfl again
i stand by those comments i believe that
at that time yes he was hot garbage you
then followed it up a few months later
with bortles was not put on earth to
throw the football
again i stand by that he admits that to
people thank you
all right and then this oh no do i think
it's stupid
oh my gosh stupid it's hilarious
that was your reaction to when he got
the new contract yes
you sound like heath ledger in the joker
yes i that's what i was channeling there
so nothing changes
after he just knocked off the patriots
in impressive no
things change this is the jumping off
spot you know me
i do last year i was saying jacksonville
is the best team in football
for the second year in a row and what
was holding them back was blake bortles
if he can just hit those plays that are
there to be had right that jacksonville
team
they are going to win the super bowl i
have no doubt about that i know
that a lot of people want you to
apologize to blake borden right
but you actually want to say you're
welcome i mean i i kept it real with you
man
you needed to put my face on some
targets in the off season and just bust
me in the face
i've given you the motivation everybody
was always saying nice things about it
he's a good guy we like him in the
locker room i just brought it real
and maybe i gave him just the nudge he
needed every morning to go
i'm going to get out of bed and prove
that [ __ ] chris sims wrong
if you end up being best friends with
blake bortles this is over because i am
your best football friend and i will not
stand for
other people being your friends don't
you worry we're bffs forever buddy old
pal i appreciate that
we think we're best football friends so
we're going to go around the league this
season
and find different friends that think
they can compete with us
with our friendship right and we're
going to start with the chargers the
melvins
melvin ingram scary dude best pass
rusher in the nfl maybe
melvin gordon three touchdowns against
buffalo they think they're friends
but are they better football friends
than us
no way no way i feel terrible cause they
trash
dude we're in trouble
[Music]
this is our referee nicole don't
disrespect her she will throw you get 15
yard penalty in there hurry around here
no problem sorry nicole easy one
lefko yeah and you guys can't just write
melvin
pick your battles wisely we can just
right hey you have to put a letter no we
don't
no we do not all right fine we're going
to listen to melvin ingram because he's
going to beat our butts
if we don't
i'm throwing the challenge flag on that
oh
all right i know i got the state right
i'm not sure
ready nebraska hmm
i think that's high that's a little too
high wasn't that great of a year
what did he rush for what is it yeah you
said it within a hundred it was
uh one thousand one hundred and
eighty-five you will assure me
he doesn't even think you're a thousand
yard rusher
wow damn i thought you knew your friend
i know what team it was
oh i i got it that definitely ain't it
his answer was show way shorter than
yours
yeah you're colorado they're in my big
12. i can't play them in the bowl game
was it
lsu nick saban you beat lsu yeah i
thought yeah
you didn't think that was possible
that's wrong
[Laughter]
gosh i'm gonna go this
oh
[Music]
sad you're coming in here and bullying
us yeah ready to be the first club
we can trust you we can get them here
come on they're like game planning over
here i don't know what they're doing
ready set go just throw it in the first
cup
yep they're all right good next one go
ahead don't oh yeah throw it in there go
ahead go again yeah go get two more
one no no all right all right
uh new cup all the way to the end there
it is come on come on i'll do the right
more i didn't touch it no no you dropped
take it out no no no no no
no i know let's hurry up i just want to
beat them right here
right there red to the third cup are you
serious yeah they beat us
you got some slime i was needing such a
steady pace
slow fat hands do it i swear i'm not
even good at this video neither i ain't
never played
much is it worth it'll be worth 10
points
how much was the first two games you
have nine and they have one
that's how you play the last game that's
how you know you deal with people who
lose all the problems i think this is
the mastermind oh so that's the key
meal you got to see if it uh if it move
don't steal it you play your game
i've never been around so many people
that have never played jenga before
pretty much that moved so easily
okay i have one hand wow you went for
that one
huh yeah i like to make it a little
harder on mg over there
look at the fear and it's oh i know how
doggy wow you're so gentle wow
what a nice touch you have yeah push it
yeah hey
that's for you right there
i love it i never talked to hr he's not
used to being hit like that velvet hit
him again
i like that's not how teamwork works
well done let go
well done
yo your pointing is so reckless i swear
any heavy-handed oh my god oh i gotta be
trying to tell him
oh his hands are heavy and big
that's it what if you don't
hold it up boy fall
aah
[Applause]
next year next year we'll come back with
a whole new set
[Music]
nobody comes on our show and beats us
ever
our show uh speaking of beating people
ryan fitzpatrick is not only beating
them on the field he's beating them in
the press conferences
everybody has seen his outfit uh kind of
look like conor mcgregor
but the look like is the key sims on the
internet a few months ago there was a
meme
called what does it look like i do for a
living we're gonna do it
quarterback edition i like it let's
start off first ryan fitzpatrick
what does it look like he does for a
living oh he looks like he is from like
the netherlands and he is a dj
at a techno club it's hans fitzpatrick
dun
dun dun dun dun
tom brady what does it look like he does
for a living this is armani's top design
too much
too little i don't like it i don't like
it i like all black all black
billy belichick you're a tiger
tom brady looks like he's the fourth
amigo i actually like this outfit all
right next
oh gosh andrew luck what does it look
like he does for 11. he sells tupperware
in the movie uh napoleon dynamite i
think that's who that is
hey look it never crushes he can put it
under a wheel
i mean that's what he looks like andrew
luck looks like a guy that's really
trying to get you hooked on a pyramid
scheme
trust me if you get your friends and
family you're going to beat millions
give me your money will says
what does it look like he does for a
living he's a stud
first of all i don't know about a stud
but it looks like he's like a guitarist
for
uh the eagles i don't know what the hell
he was trying to do there he looks like
the guy that bullies people at the local
dojo
he looks like uh put him in a body bag
john yes he looks at the guy
he can put him in a body bag johnny do
you think he's gonna be upset when he
sees this uh he'll get over it
what's up i'm sam darnold and screw sims
you're watching sam and lefko
i love sam darnold i am a fan are you a
fan i am a fan
i hope so i am don't just don't be a
stalker dude we've noticed with the la
teams fans are an issue so sims and i
went to la
and we wanted to recruit fans i
recruited for the rams i went for the
la iphone chargers yeah we made our own
logos i kind of like yours more than
mine
it's cooler and it's sims versus lefko
who could get more fans
for their team you're going down why did
you touch my ear
i'm gonna pay you this compliment one of
the most attractive men on this beach oh
see eric now he's a liar
we're in southern california there's a
lot of handsome people here
why don't you go first and try to
convince them to be a charger well you
can't root for the rams anymore they
already left la once so they don't
really like la i don't think
the chargers you got phillip rivers
going to be a hall of famer akeeb to
leap
in damakunsu and the youngest head coach
he's not that much older than you
the rams okay was like a bad divorce
the charges were good but without a home
so it's like a broken home actually i'm
going with
ah yes i like the honesty actually that
he's getting ready
yes there you go eric chargers
if you choose the rams there's someone
that every sunday they're gonna bring
you joy you know what they're gonna
bring you
constipation so who you picking with the
rams put that baby on
i'm one can i get both you know when i
think hollywood and i think the
spotlight i definitely see
todd gurley and jared goff together oh
baby
pick a hat and put it on yeah
yeah here from australia going to see
which time
is the better team i really wanted he's
adobe he's adobe
it's kind of like a newborn kangaroo
fresh feeling good
springy little hoppy you did do a great
australian accent
yes ride the riptide we're going to
catch some waves we're going to shred
the gnar
they're all hollywood it's all about we
look pretty and cool
but they're not really proven you know
what i'm just going to let you have gail
you like the chargers or the rams better
yeah this is great the next team picked
is the winner of the la fan chad i
thought this shoot was over already and
i won
what position did you try out for the
chargers
incredible and then you grew up a fan of
what team the los angeles ran
okay so we're even here sims yeah when
you walked up here rod i went
is that aaron donald with his shirt off
you know what tv plays for
i'm going with durant
[Applause]
rams the team of la sims i had a double
dipper with the daughter and the father
and that should have been two of my hats
these last rounds didn't even count
winner i won
i mean he's always like this it's beyond
frustrating
my hope with somebody in lefko was we
were going to find somebody that was the
oracle
a better that hadn't bet yet ally is
two for two and he's nailing it this
week
jets travel to cleveland browns are
favored by three
the only person i'm trusting with my
money is ally
this smile on my face is because my man
ally is back to back
he's the oracle and i think he's going
for 3.
[Music]
[Applause]
my man adam how you doing brother how
are you doing i'm good because i have
119 and five cents
i like it congratulations thank you
you're blowing my mind
now listen i told you i was gonna let it
build up right so i have the 113 from
last week
on top of where's the 65 cents i
have it i have it wow so you're really
building it up absolutely
see i was doubting you but now i'm all
aboard the alley train
just like your boy chris right he said
all i can do is sell newspapers right
yeah you got something you'd like to say
to him really oh i can do a little bit
more than sell newspapers chris
this week's game it is the jets jess
jets jets they travel to cleveland
cleveland is the favorite where are you
going take me through the mental mindset
well i'm a jets fan they're both coming
off losses but i like
darnell snapping back you do i do so if
he did have some picks but he threw for
345 you think darnold bounces back and
then
who wins the game i like the jets wow
straight up win yep
you've heard it here first don't listen
to sims and me pick
only listen to the oracle alley
jets j-e-t-s jets
jets jet 2-0 he's taken over your
nickname
he is going the jets plus three in
cleveland are you finally ready to agree
with ali
hell no ally let's go brownies i'm going
to browns
they're at home there's a little rivalry
that i think could blossom yeah
almost as good as your bortles rivalry
all right so bortles you famously had
them at 70. we've been talking all show
you're moving them up because how he's
played the last two games certainly
and the playoffs right your new number
for blake bortles at this moment is
i don't have a specific number but he's
in the mid-30s i got to evaluate
everybody here it's week two but i know
between the afc championship game the
first two weeks of the year
mid-thirties he's mid-thirties you had
eli at 38 last season is he ahead of eli
yes that's not yes not even a question
not even a question i would rather have
blake bortles than eli manning he can
run
he'll stand in the pocket and make
throws and bortles is tough as hell
are you saying that eli manning's face
on sunday night isn't tough
take a look into the eyes of an absolute
toughest nails competitor
eli what sound do you think he's making
oh gosh don't hit me they're not paying
me enough for this
so i want to know what every quarterback
in the nfl's
faces when they get sacked so we're
creating the hashtag sackface
we're talking about quarterbacks so when
you're watching your quarterback on
sunday
hit dvr when he gets sacked hit that
pause button and send it to us on
twitter with the hashtag
sackface we're talking about
quarterbacks what do you think you're
sacrificing oh
tough fearless just like bringing on ray
lewis julius peppers
you can't bring me down that's pretty
much i think it was more like uh please
don't do this to me
pull the whistle blow the whistle find
his sack face picture too again the
hashtag
sackface for sims peace out homie i am
the l-e-f-k-o-e
man and it's always been a pleasure sims
and lufko we're out enjoy the games
all right those are my two hey mckee be
real with you you watched them write 11.
oh
yeah it can't be he did it just like
this oh well my dad was 11 too so it was
like
he did not know 11. i didn't he got it
wrong because i didn't wear it too hey
honest to god did you get 11 from him
and i have a feud
hey what's up homies thanks for watching
subscribe to the br
youtube channel man you're such a
millennial also while you're here
we have a lot of other videos check them
out and then what time does our show
come out
wednesday 8 p.m be there or
be square he ruined it it was really
close